[Music]
Ishod it's a pity my three children
received their confirmation in this
church and now it is a mosque but what
can you do
[Music]
it's awful when a church gets removed
for a mosque although they really made
it beautiful of course it is a different
culture and faith sure but there are
also so many parallels and therefore we
have to be reasonable and stand together
when I just looked past I had a strange
feeling a little bit frightening
when I'm in the bus for example and I
see a crowd of people coming from a
mosque it is a frightening feeling
because we feel as a stranger's house
[Music]
a mosque is a place of integration and
learning I don't think you can say that
a German is a christian automatically
nowadays
you